wie lang ist der
Nil
Afrika
ja und damit darf ich euch recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
weiteren Episode Luca reagiert auf
witzige Schülerantworten Luca bin ich
witzige Schülerantworten sind das was
wir uns hier gerade angeschaut haben und
ich würde sagen wir machen auch direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten denn das ist die
Frage was besagt der Satz des
Pythagoras was hat ein Satz mit Mathe zu
tun
ich habe das Gefühl dass jede Antwort
hier von Sandra ist machen wir
allerdings weiter mit der nächsten
lustigen schülerantwort und einer Frage
die in einer Klassenarbeit der Klasse 7
gestellt wurde denn man sollte sagen
wofür die Farben der deutschen Flagge
stehen die Person schreibt blau steht
für den
Himmel h Kollege ganz kurz für dich noch
mal die Info das hier ist die deutsche
Flagge keine Ahnung wo da irgendwas blau
sein soll aber gut er lässt sich davon
auf jeden Fall nicht beirren und macht
weiter mit der Farbe weiß das steht
nämlich für die Freiheit also ich meine
okay das Blau vielleicht für ein Himmel
stehen könnte und weiß für Freiheit das
liegt jetzt nicht so so weit von der
Hand
aber ich komme dir da noch mal
entgegen ich komme dir entgegen mach ein
Abschuss das hier ist die
Flagge von
Deutschland da ist auch nirgends wo weiß
drin er lässt sich davon allerdings noch
immer nicht beirren und gibt als letzte
Farbe das richtige an und zwar rot steht
für Blut weiß jetzt auch nicht ob rot
für Blut stehen soll aber laut ihm ist
die Flagge anscheinend
Frankreich und nicht Deutschland oder so
würde ich sagen machen wir weiter mit
der nächsten lustigen schülerantwort und
zwar WD die Frage gestellt worauf kann
Moos im Rasen hindeuten auf Moos im
Rasen
machen wir allerdings direkt weiter mit
der nächsten lustigen schülerantwort und
zwar wurde in einer physiklauso gefragt
welches Elementsymbol Schwefel besitzt
die Antwort des Schülers war Schwefel
mit drei so keine Ahnung wahrscheinlich
s so stinkende rauchdinger sein weil
Schwefel ja giftig ist keine
Ahnung Physik direkt abgewählt als es
ging ich habe da so reingeschissen so od
so sag machen wir direkt weiter was wohl
korrekt der nächst lustigen
schülerantwort hier sollte eine Person
beantworten wie lange Angela Merkel
Bundeskanzlerin war die Person antwortet
da Angela Merkel noch immer
Bundeskanzlerin ist kann man diese Frage
noch nicht beantworten und wenn sie das
noch immer wäre wäre diese Antwort ja
richtig in der Frage steht allerdings
schon wie lange war Angela Merkel
Bundeskanzlerin und sie ist es ja OBV
sie dementsprechend nicht mehr deswegen
gibt auch die Antwort keinen Sinn und
ich würde dir damit null Punkte geben
und dich von der Schule schmeißen lassen
sass du keine Zukunft hast GI wie
entstehen
Flüsse sehr interessante Frage ich
glaube es liegt do irgendwie daran dass
aus Gletschern Quellen etc das Wasser
rausfließt und sich dann irgendwann über
die letzten Milliarden Jahre irgendwie
so seinen Weg gesucht hat an der Erde
und dadurch sind dann halt irgendwann so
diese Flüsse entstanden der Schüler hat
allerdings ganz andere Begründung und
zwar schreibt er weil das Wasser ja
nicht stehen
kannokanten Fragezeichen hter als wenn
die Lehrerin komplett dumm gewesen wäre
bei der Frage so oder so würde ich
allerdings sagen machen wir direkt
weiter mit der nächsten lustigen
schülerantwort und zwar ziemlich simpel
welche Landesvorwahl hat Deutschland
ganz kurz für euch zu Info Landesvorwahl
ist eigentlich halt die Null die ist ja
eigentlich in jedem Land gleich aber
dann haben hat man manchmal + 41 + 49
beispielsweise ist Deutschland und das
ist halt diese Telefonvorwahl war früher
ein größeres Ding als jetzt heutzutage
weil das Handy das selbst irgendwi
erkennt so oder so schreibt der Schüler
069 ich glaube der ist haftbefehlfan
machen wir allerdings direkt schon
weiter mit der nächsten ah lustigen
schülerantwort hier sollte man nämlich
folgende deutsche Sprichwörter beenden
beer Nummer ein schreibt der Lehrer wer
zuerst kommt normalerweise kommt dann so
malt zuerst ich dachte früher übrigens
dass es malen ist aber wer zuerst kommt
malt zuerst mit H also malen aner Mühle
malen so oder so schreibt der Schüler
dahin wer zuerst kommt hat Stress mit
Freunden
wegen kommen
weiter geht's mit Sprichwort Nummer 2
hochmut kommt und
geht hochmut kommt vor dem Fall wä es
eigentlich gewesen machen wir weiter mit
Nummer 3 was du heute kannst besorgen
dann besorg
halt es ist so dumm es ist nicht alles
Gold sondern auch
Silber korrekt ausnahmen bestätigen
eigentlich die Regel aber hier heißt es
Ausnahmen bestätigen und verneinen
h auch nicht verstanden dann hat er
allerdings auf jeden Fall zwei richtig
denn aller Anfang ist schwer und
Morgenstund hat Gold im Mund hat er noch
hingekriegt der letzte Satz war dann
allerdings der apfelfät nicht weit vom
Stamm er hat geschrieben der apfelfät
wenn er reif ist ist auch korrekt würde
ich dir Z Punkte geben so oder so wür
ich sagen machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten lustigen schülerantwort korrekt
der nächsten lustigen schülerantwort
hier sollte man nämlich jeweils drei
Geräusche in die Tabelle eintragen und
die Tabelle war unterteilt in angenehme
schulgeräusche und unangenehme
schulgeräusche Spalte Nummer ein wenn
die Pausenglocke klingelt ist seiner
Ansicht nach ein angenehmes
schulgeräusch unangenehm auf der
Gegenseite wenn die unterrchtsblocke
kegt angenehm dann wiederum wenn die
Jungs reden unangenehm wenn die Mädchen
reden und angenehm noch mal wenn die
Mädchen leise sind und unangenehm wenn
die Mädchen so blöd kichern ganz unten
hat er dann geschrieben hier ist eine
extra Zeit oder Spalte zu viel kriege
ich dafür ein extra Punkt keine Ahnung
ob er den bekommen hat ich weiß aber
generell nicht ob er überhaupt Punkt für
die Aufgabe bekommen hat bei der
nächsten lustigen schülerantwort musste
der Schüler Abkürzungen beschreiben also
ausführlich dann sagen für was die halt
stehen bei der ersten Sache ging es
tatsächlich um das Wort Abkürzung also
ABK er schreibt allerdings Abu
schaka bei erg schreibt der ärgerlich
diger das ist in so vielen Richtungen
falsch und bei sing was für Singular
steht schreibt er
DSDS Bro singen steht nicht für singen
so oder so meine Damen und Herren machen
wir allerdings weiter mit der nächsten
lustigen schülerantwort denn hier war
die Aufgabe erläutere die Funktion der
großen inneren Oberfläche des dünndabens
keine Ahnung diger hatte der Schüler
auch nicht dann einfach irgendwas
hingeschrieben was sich schlau anhören
sollte im Endeffekt Betracht besteht die
substive Hypotenuse aus der inneren
Oberfläche weil der stationäre
vegetative dündarm sich
erholt
genau was ist die Definition einer
mathematischen Funktion sie blöder Idiot
meinten dass sowas heute nicht drank
kommmt und
das kann ich jetzt nicht
bezeugen aber wenn der Lehrer gesagt hat
das kommt nicht und es kommt trotzdem
ist ein übelster h Aufgabe Nummer 4
erkläre den Begriff Vakuum
leer volle Punktzahl und mit dieser
vollen Punktzahl meine Damen und Herren
weil ich gestern auch ordentlich voll
war danke alles gut danke so oder so
kommen wir damit jetzt auch schon zur
letzten lustigen schülerantwort die aus
sechs Antworten besteht denn man sollte
h ein paar Fragen beantworten Frage
Nummer ein sind sie kindisch er hat ein
Haus gemalt aus der Schachtel wo er
ankreuzen sollte Aufgabe Nummer 2 sind
sie nervös nein und er hat's komplett
zugemalt als wä er geisterkrank nervös
egal Sache Nummer 3 sind sie paranoid
nein
warum sind sie rassistisch und er malt
das komplett aus um Halt zu zeigen weiß
schwarz keine Ahnung was ja Frage Nummer
5 sind sie betrunken der trifft das
neinkreuz nicht und bei Frage Nummer 6
treffen sie Entscheidungen da hat er
einfach
das gut meine Damen und Herren das war's
vom heutigen Video